this is roses scabbard I don't think
that can be taken any other way yeah I'm
I I definitely got a vibe out of this
one that was interesting how about you I
think the vibe has been there for a
while then I thought it's been there for
a long time now but now it seems really
out in the open there's no yeah there
way that's gonna be taken as nothing
else I mean they said it in every way
but name-o hurry hurry action pearls
reaction to rose to basically Steven
knowing things at Rose would have is
like a jealous lover
ya know very much yeah and um so like
the scene where the picture fell like
right there I'm like okay I feel like
really going we're committing to this
now like and then I but like I thought
maybe they're gonna milk it another
episode or two but by the end of this
episode I'm like whoa ya know I won
that'd be amazing if just only like the
Creator comes out is just like oh this
really good friends no she was like
again I guess like yeah like burns and
Smithers are good friends
yeah I I think it's every funny fucking
everything but name by I don't even
think you need to be completely silent
it makes them no compelling characters
but no I know I'm like okay so this I'm
like were committing to this I guess
here's what I really like about this cuz
you know what I read the lesbian couple
gay couple whatever it's not really
shocking at all anymore what I really
find so it's like well how can you get
anything like super interesting or why
even build this up or keep it secret
thing and it one may okay like with
Korra and everything there's the
prejudice you gotta tread lightly and
stuff but for me what makes really
interesting uh and really complex is
that again Rose is half Steven uh but
they're they're not playing that at all
like oh hey she finds a little boy
attractive or anything like that is that
she sees Rose in Steven bow yeah nobody
topic which is an interesting idea no
but because you know even though I
personally I mean cannot think of anyone
I've met in my life that has done this
or gone through this but you know
there's people out there that whatever
hate a child because they remind them of
somebody either they love or they hate
it or both um and I get a lot of that
from that even though it's like she's
raising him and everything they're still
like this when he was holding education
I do get it all but she can't help him I
it's very subconscious it seems to me
yeah like I don't I don't get it active
like cuz she's protected Steven
plenteous ya know is there are times
when there is something buried in there
there's like whew ya know definitely
like and I hate it's the I think Steven
it she hates the way Steven reminds her
of the past I think is what's got around
there um and yeah this is this is like a
fucking can of worms of psychological
issues this whole episode what wow yeah
I think with this one and um and you
know how easy would it have been to have
pearl replace a Bethesda an episode
where they watch a little Butler and
stuff like that I mean suddenly it's
like two out of the three gems kind of
look at Steven say hey we're gonna
protect you and you know we love you and
everything I mean they're nervous of the
history and some baggage here yeah we
they're sorry this deep-seated like you
kind of changed everything and in some
respects maybe even ruined a few things
but we can't admit that to ourselves and
I will say you don't want it to the
brilliance of the story once the plot
actually gets moving because it does
take a while but once it gets moving the
brilliance of the story is this we're
all finding out about this kind of as
Steven is in these bits and pieces of
wow there's there's an actual history
here this wasn't one big flash bag dump
like slowly we're learning that like it
there's trouble in paradise here that's
been going on right and you're finding
out about the right way you're finding
out through the it's not what's this
place well let me talk for hours about
it's like know somebody goes with shouse
key method yeah
somebody goes through some
what's wrong with them and you spend the
whole episode confronting their emotions
but to find out about the emotions you
have to know what's going on like they
also tell you okay which house keys
shyamalan they should all take yeah I
mean this is very naturally done and so
much is being said again I mean we go on
and on about this all the time but so
much is being said with what's not being
said I think her looking over making
sure he's okay soul and to the vine but
not helping him oh that was I just met
says my dog hit the ground I was like
wouldn't Steven climbed up I was like
thanks for the hell what but you also
get it when you see her edge at that
wonderful drawing on her of her just
covering half her face you know oh she
was in the middle of a fucking meltdown
yeah like she was just get it she was
gone and bye-bye land for a little bit
there like I yeah I I don't even think
that it was consciously like I'm gonna
let Steven fall I think she was
literally paralyzed with depression or
anxiety or something well she's already
kind of neurotic so or something they're
just too paralyzed to do anything like
just sitting there like I said she I was
like if he's okay like if he was really
in danger I I would do I would go get it
but you know it he get out of if I'm
sure if she heard a snap in it yeah oh
you should go after him yeah but I think
she had some feeling like he can do it
himself
yeah um I think they so well capture
certain elements of Steven as a child at
the line you got to tell me I love that
like is that something I can't forget as
a kid where it's like you kind of think
there's these rules why as a parent you
got to tell me if it's the rule and it's
like what there are no real rules but
it's something where he's kind of right
- it's like why aren't you doing what
should be very obvious and explaining
this or showing or whatever um so yeah I
find it again though I like the fact
that that kind of you know buried I
don't want to say hatred but can we you
said meet jealousy that buried jealousy
is always there no it's not jealousy
but but what's the word I'm looking for
is that jelly she's not jealous of
Steven it I think regret I literally
like it this Steven reminds her of the
past is okay notice you know what Erica
would you're right you're right that
there was there was jealousy we're going
to the Father you're right I'm probably
more of a gret though I think you're
right to make it again yeah I think in
the end it's it's mostly regret I think
she misses Rose for reasons that seemed
pretty clear to me
um but yeah and at first I think it's
like a jealous lover like well Rose is
confident I knew Rose unlike anyone else
you know and I I think jealousy
kick-starts it because also rose and
Stevens dad there had to be jealousy
there yeah you know but I think I think
in the end when it all comes down to it
it's just she doesn't she just does not
want to face you know roses death hmm
like she has all this worries she has
all this regret I mean she obviously had
some relationship here Rose is gone all
of that is gone and she has this
constant fucking reminder staring her in
the face and I think she's okay with
that because she sees it as an extension
of helping rose but I think when that
moment happened when it's just like oh I
know about all these things is just like
but but I was the one left but again it
rants word into jealousy about well I
think what makes even tougher is that it
was a choice that Rose made Rose chose
ya become half-human Helen you saw that
flashback was fuckin amazing where it's
just the look in pearls eyes was like I
will follow you to the end I don't want
to be with you to the other one it's
like you have to imagine that afterwards
though hooking up with Stevens and
everything and feel like a sense of
betrayal well is and here's the thing
Rose said my pearl I mean that has to be
okay she's aware oh no that was possess
action my pearl yeah no I mean but yeah
that is you know she has to at the very
least know that pearl has an attraction
to her and is either trying to let her
down easily or or maybe Shannon
uh you know and this is not like a
sexual love it is definitely an intimate
soulmate kind of like at least to me I'm
reading it as like above and beyond you
know
oh we're just BFFs like yeah there is
something going on here even if you know
the show is that willing to take it to
that level hmm um but I mean oh it like
a Sammy I think they like whether or not
they could say it or not you know I mean
it's it likes its it really is to a
point it just it can't be anything else
it just can't uh the the big question
for me is whether or not how far did
Rose kind of go with it
you know were they ever a couple or was
it more look I understand and we have
these feelings but this can to happen
because of whatever she's in love with
Stevens disagrees oh my girls i I think
jealousy is half of it but I think the
fact that Rose is dead and obviously it
did not hit any of them I think that
adds another layer on top of it ya know
I honestly I think I think it really
comes down to regret and maybe that you
know not jealousy well because of the
confident thing but more like we don't
know what happened maybe pearl didn't
pursue it as far as she could have maybe
she's got regret over that it's like
well now this is all I get the feeling
whenever i watch pearl and she's talking
there that there's this feeling of well
now it's all too late like this is all
just ghosts in the past and this Amanda
well that's what he's gonna say do in
her head whenever she talks about Rose
it's super confident and and they were
best buds and she was phenomenal and
everyone talks well about her but she
especially sings her praises but it's
also everyday she's looking at this
choice that Rose made I mean every day
she looks at Stephen not only does she
see this choice that Rose made but she
sees you know Rose as well well and that
may be part of the thing it's like
Steven knowing about this maybe they
built rose up in her memories in the
back of her head probably more than you
know it's like a hero worship yeah so
that maybe I think part of it the
jealousy kicked in because that was a
chink in the armor of like but Rose was
so perfect she wouldn't do that to me
yeah well she did heaven knows he's it
like by me but the ultimate thing I mean
on top of that keeping the secrets away
I think there's a sense like she had to
hold on to that because you know she
sings her praises and everything but I
part of it I think is there's this
interesting case of denial where it's
like I can claim we were the closest and
we were soul may where all these things
but she still went free Stephens dad she
left her to go for Stephens dad and even
oh man there's like total denial and the
problem is reality is now caught up to
her because we now have proved that rose
may have confided things into Stephen
and I think just the the previous
episode you know not too long ago with
the the storage locker
yeah all that shit comes flooding back
like you know I think now now that
Stephens getting older it's like she can
just bury it and put in her head I'm
like well everything was hunky-dory
because you get the distinct impression
the other gems aren't talking about rose
either so they're they're not going into
anything heavy you notice they they try
to keep Stephen out of it they try to so
Pearl's allowed herself to basically
build this past backstory in her head
and hero worship and now literally
reality's invading it it's like breaking
down the shell she's old and it's like
well no here's what really is going on
well I don't even think it's necessary
for Stephen I think she's convinced
herself that like the two of them I mean
after she left it's like you hit this
you know Kylie you said you know the
feeling of betrayal almost like you know
what she's going with this human oh no
and abandoning herself so it's like you
know I'm gonna build up she's about 14
though she was little high of them have
also said were not they've been keeping
things from Steven and I think I'm
purpose so they'll talk about the mother
occasionally but the whole backstory
with the you know there may be other
gems trying to destroy the earth and all
that that's been kept secret and you
notice the other gems I don't think took
it very well when Rose died either they
don't seem to talk about it much they
talk about it politely and oh yes your
mother was really great in this and that
but I don't see anything really deep the
circle down these old casts of a cartoon
yeah garnet and amethyst and pearl when
the three of them are to get
other how many deep conversations do
they have so it seems like they all are
not addressing the subject all that much
which is a loud pearl to do this like
and I don't think garnet and amethyst
did that to help pearl I just think they
all were just like well it's kind of
painful like you don't talk about it
much you don't want to talk about your
dead friends much I can bring up
memories but it's a loud pearl to do
this and Steven now like that he's
getting old enough and the past is being
dug up is breaking down that image like
reality's literally invading pearls head
I think it's she can't cope let me write
down to garnet and amethyst will
particularly garnet let Steven go to fix
it like they didn't go I mean she said
yes lock I mean there's a sense you
really are the only one that can do this
not just because you're so open and nice
and you're Steven and stuff like that
but your Rose you know you're half Rose
pretty much and I think that's in that
might be another aspect of the jealousy
is it unintentionally it's like this
kids growing up and now he's ruining my
perfect image of my hero like you know
I'm having to face this shit for the
first time so ya know it was uh I mean
it's a good that does a treasure trove
of shit gonna yeah the one last thing
I'll comment on is the how easy would
have been if they just ended on him
hugging her from behind and her crying
and you could just out there I like that
they kept going and they allowed her to
have her moment again where she's like
explaining the battles and stuff like
that and allowing her to show off and
everything and it is now kind of like
well now is kind of their special play
they had this nice little moment and you
know I'm not just hey I broke down and
this embarrassing thing you know it's
like she I liked Jimmy could tell these
stories and impress me like the image of
them on the lion in her carrying the
battle flag it was very it was a great
metaphor for we're moving forward mark
yeah so um and again I'm what a great
episode I'm kind of waiting for that
like when they're on the Lion cuz they
hold a chef for a while I'm waiting for
it to be like I didn't know like either
like she puts her hand on shoulder or
like rubs his head or something like
that that's actually just sort of looks
for both like both really broken but you
know
starting to get fixed - you know it's
starting to heal um you know like she's
trying to put herself back together you
know it just sort of looks forward looks
a Steve and then just so it looks
forward again like it's not like a smile
or anything like I thought that even
though I would have hated or anything if
I well then just a hint too much I like
those a little bit more ambiguous um
so yeah I think that's probably all we
can say about that one I mean not like
we had little to say about it um maybe
the line was roses so that's why it's
pink yeah when you think about it it's
pretty obvious um yeah that's the one
thing I'm really curious to hear where
the lion I mean obviously the lion was
Rosa but like what we've established
adds like how did he fit into this yeah
I mean if the lion always know I had
always meant we're even
yeah where to go what to get what time
to do as a general of roses things
inside his er there is does that lion
have a gender like cuz it's been
established er it's good say he's my
broker I think he says he but I guess
it's a Asin
maybe the Pink's throwing me off nother
size where he has eyelashes - but I'm
pretty sure he said he oh whatever it's
yeah but um yeah but you also see some
of like her father stuff and it - what
the VHS was in there the first time we
see her - or a steam his father sodas in
there
so um ya know a really good episode and
yeah very revealing very emotional and
that that's that's how you do it you
know I think whenever people say well a
lot of movies are supposed to be
explaining as - I think this is why we
are so mad no but this is why I think we
are so hard on movies that
over-explained stuff because this is
what you're missing this is a good
combination
no doubt I mean you can tell a little
you need words I mean they're not saying
this is visual and verbal but it's like
yeah I mean use the combination use
everything though yes Midori naturally
organically don't write four paragraphs
of text and just have one actor deliver
it and like it did yeah um so no
definitely really
enjoyed it and we will see at the next
one later